on this season of cabin land you're
gonna see us build a real house we're
gonna show you almost every step of the
process along the way like any old house
it is three cabins connected by floating
hallways all three cabins are the same
shape but just ratioed sizes of each
other so and they're all next to each
other it's like if you you made one and
then you copied it and pasted it and
like made it a little bigger and then
copied it and pasted it and made it a
little bigger and that's what its gonna
be
[Music]
the first thing we have to do is build
the model the reason we like to build
the model is it really gives a visual
representation of what it's actually
gonna look like each of the three cabins
are twice as tall as they are wide so
I'm really anxious to see what they're
really gonna look like I'm not super
worried but I am a little worried so I'm
not worried yes I am so being able to
see this this afternoon is either going
to call my fears about how skinny and
tall they are or it's gonna make me
nervous
it is time to build our model we are
very excited to do this because it is
great to be able to see what the cabin
is gonna look like in a 3d physical form
this is a 1:24 scale model of it so what
we have is these quarter inch by quarter
inch sticks that we've already cut up
then we're just gonna use a hot glue gun
and a blow-dryer to put them together
and the blow dryer blows cold air when
we turn rinsing the plans that we have
for this a lot and using this thing to
measure the angles and the lengths so
let's get started on these plans half an
inch equals one foot a 16 foot by 16
foot gets reduced down to an 8 inch by 8
inch
[Music]
this is mother that's the ceiling of the
kitchen that's nine feet that oh my god
our bet our bedroom there's weight ah so
this is gonna be the biggest cabin which
is actually going to be two stories
about the roof of the bedrooms gonna be
like up here so it's going to be crazy
tall ceilings and with good reason I
burn this out of myself every single
time
[Music]
ATB since 1983 sorry my bad don't you
love it smell of light that smells like
you just did the laundry smell your [ __ ]
I am a good listener whoa nice look
there's a mouse and a bat down better
the man okay now we're putting on the
roof
so you just start seeing the pitches
[Music]
all right our house yes the whole house
is done no um this relieved a lot of
anxiety for me because this is this is
more how I pictured it would be not like
skyscrapers yeah I think proportionally
they look good all together this front
little one is gonna be the living room
this back here is gonna be laundry room
slash bathroom this big one kitchen
downstairs bedroom bathroom upstairs
most of the cabins we build are like 90
square feet this is a full-on house and
it's gonna be 800 just over 800 feet
square feet yes let's no we have to go
watch America's Next Top Model need some
vegan sausage okay okay ready yeah nice
[Music]
today with build the floor
as you can see it's raining but that's
pretty hardcore
[Music]
[Music]